et l'on reparle de la sphère du petit
grégory à l'occasion des obsèques
aujourd'hui de la mer de marie-ange
laroche les pousses de bernard laroche
un moment soupçonné du crime est
assassiné par son beau frère jean marie
villemin la polémique vient du fait que
l'un des avocats de la famille laroche
estime que c'est la récente libération
provisoire de jean marie villemin en
attendant son jugement qui a choqué la
mère de marie ange laroche au point de
décéder d'une crise cardiaque à l'âge de
57 ans et le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que l'atmosphère était
particulièrement tendue pendant la
cérémonie des obsèques cet après midi
isabel peichert lave ligne devant
bruyère vosges dans cette vallée de la
vologne où les victimes de l'affairé
grégory ne se comptent plus le deuil a
encore frappé du côté des laroche
jeanine bol est décédé voilà trois jours
à l'âge de 57 ans elle était mère de dix
enfants dont marie-ange la veuve de
bernard laroche et muriel qui avait mis
en cause son beau-frère pour toute cette
famille la vie avait basculé avec la
faire voilà trois ans entre eux aussi
vraiment ayad la justice je veux qu'il
faut chercher la chose et qu'on sache la
vérité une vérité est acquise c'est jean
marie villemin qui a tué bernard laroche
le libérer c'était comme tuer bernard
une seconde fois pour sa famille
après un moment de consternation au
moment des indignations au moment de
colère et après la tristesse provoqué
par la mort de madame ball mère de marie
ange laroche et grand mère de sébastien
laroche qui n'a pas supporté le choc et
qui en est morte
c'est une volonté de justice que jean
marie villemin passe aux assises mais
aussi de volonté que ce dossier soit
confié dossier d'instruction la mort de
grégory villemin le dossier
d'instruction concernant la plainte
contre les gendarmes sont confiés aide à
un magistrat qui ne soit pas le juge
simon qui a montré trop de partialité
aux yeux de la famille laroche la
libération de jean marie villemin
traduit la volonté d'étouffer la faire
et non pas de rechercher la vérité au
cours jean marie villemin assassiné
bernard laroche des loges je ne suis pas
convaincu que l'on veut vraiment trouver
l'assassin de grégory villemin
vous ne verrez de cet enterrement qu'un
cimetière vide dans sa douleur et son
indignation la famille n'a pas pu
maîtriser sa colère des menaces et des
voies de fait ont découragé les
journalistes présents dans la région